[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
pourquoi
à la question qu'est ce
en france
[Musique]
oh
joue pendant qu'il faisait chaque
badaboum
achtung achtung faut faire attention
parce que si on commence à être sur la
pente savonneuse et ben commence à
descendre des 160 et puis quand on se
retrouve à la station en bas on est plus
sur les pistes je vais donc prendre la
température de tout le monde avec ce
qu'on appelle le pistolet c'est le père
shoah
moi aussi j'ai très très peur et vous
attend sur la tempe ariz une réponse
ce titre son émission préférée du moment
mais chérie je la dois à cela je le mets
tous les matins dans ma douche et je
peux vous dire j'ai l'impression que je
suis encore plus beau tout nu dans un
instant je vais prendre la température
de mon corps peut-être je suis souffrent
bien pire que ça matar d'une maladie qui
s'appelle le coronavirus et qui fait
naturel de l'ong 6,9
j'aurais aimé plus de chasse pilote de
chasse dans le métro ça ne choque pas du
tout ban on a bon moral ratp
rassemblement autour d'un terrible pénis
le caprice des dieux et des planches on
dirait muc
son corps
[Musique]
quant à rooney l'abri
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
conte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tak tak badaboum soins de soins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et merde à 21 ans 12 en direct n'est
plus l'animateur qui vous parle et c'est
l'inspecteur baba moi je vous dis à
chaque fois même que j'arrive dans une
maison je casse tout les murs pour
savoir si à des trésors derrière son nom
maintenant j'ai pas chromé ou non mais
c'est vrai les étapes au mur comme ça
que tu es bien sûr je suis comme ça je
fais à ma mère maman et à trésor parce
que vous venez de 8,2 chimie ne sont pas
débloqués marche pas j'avais déjà fait
des rites société a commencé et ça c'est
quoi le dernier très engagé truc c'est
parce que tabasco ça sent pas bon
[Musique]